fighting these time wizards and it is so
when they eyedrops yeah one yes yes
there are Cronin's in the eye drops
that's true that's here take my eye
drops yeah yeah can't wait to talk about
next week yeah we can't talk about it
just yet on gamespot com we have a bunch
of preview like videos of a better we
did some live streams of chapter 1
chapter 2 with the best embargo listing
I have a description I've ever seen in
my life last week we were allowed to
play the game chapter 2 up until the
point the Toto's Africa played oh why is
it that song keeps like a recurring or
like reappearing and things that we do
right cuz it's still the closest people
have gotten to perfect musically okay
yeah I mean vice city did it was all
been talking up Hilson said anyway we're
not here to talk about old grunt of all
our games from two thousand and guess
when was I said he can't wait to come in
guess listeners mmm thousand three what
are you gonna say I was gonna say we're
not gonna go undercut you doesn't to I
was gonna say 2003 as well it came out
in 2002 he's right they go October
that's your vice city information for
today thank you so much watching the
show if you're watching live on
twitch.tv i will be sending are we
keeping an eye out for cuestiones if
you're watching is on the mound thank
you so much put your comments in the
comment box below if you're watching
this in your ear holes thank you so much
for subscribing to lobby on itunes or
stitcher or any other of the weirds
podcast things that right there like
chrono that's probably one right sure
that it is I bed and watch upper
watchdogs I bet in quantum break sure
they have their own like podcast feed
thing in there that's what you watch the
TV show on a bit it's called crong crong
tunes on it looks like run all right
let's talk about real video games let's
talk about overwatch everyone's talking
about overwatch we're not gonna talk
about that part of a lunch let's set
that spot continue on there what I want
to talk to you about Mike McCarty I've
been playing over watchin past couple
months and then the beta it's coming out
in a couple of months time may third may
third just around the corner yeah couple
of corners but you know just ran a
couple of corners and but we've been
playing predominately on PC and most of
the gameplay we've seen has been pc but
you got to go down to blow
play it on consoles yeah so I guess
first of all what did you play it on
xbox one playstation 4 i played
playstation 4 Dave over in the UK dead
xbox one they've jewett yep and yeah I
played about three or four hours on ps4
it feels good feels I mean like you'd
expect I the default aiming sensitivity
fell a little slow but i think that was
mainly just because i was so used to
playing on pc where you could do a 180
degree turn and like no time flat yeah
but even so it's the game itself is
designed to be very fast-paced so i
think a lot of people might be turning
their sensitivity up even if you're not
normally accustomed to that because like
most the character abilities are kind of
tailored for this really like in some
cases twitchy gameplay like Widowmaker
i'm sure the sniper people are like
really good on pc with her yeah on
console it's gonna be a little more you
know adjusting if people were used to pc
but have they changed any of the heroes
abilities because like Widowmaker is the
one that like you play Widowmaker like
you put counter-strike sure it sits
straight and down sights there's a
charge on the sniper rifle but it's it's
pretty much like Hanzo almost white yeah
same thing Atlanta but like for instance
Winston the big ape his he's almost like
one of the easier characters because his
gun essentially like just connects to
anyone who's read so like that's one
that would be simple on consoles yeah
changing any of the like tweaking
characters at a team like runnin no I
mean that from what they've told me from
when I played it was very similar or it
was it was the same thing from what
they've said they're even getting you
know they're gonna be updating it
simultaneously on all platforms they
said they'd be open to cross play
between xbox one ps4 if that actually
happens but they they've said this a few
times they're not gonna do pc console
because i would just be allowed back
yeah they don't want the dreamcast quake
3 thing top and a gun right where it'll
go waiting for that one publisher be
like we do not want cross-play between
ps4 xbox okay what publisher is not
going to say that that's what they want
yeah it's good yeah we want it's one
injector yeah so yeah and so how does it
i guess if it if it's up it must felt it
must have felt like it was playing at a
slightly different pace right because i
guess it's hard to tell because a if you
play with noobs the first time around
it's always gonna be a little bit slower
as well were you playing against
blizzard folk were you playing with
other journalists or youtubers what was
it like it was journalists and youtubers
but they all seem pretty experienced
i was i consider myself decent at
shooters and overwatch I've been playing
a lot on PC and I was you know like it
was a challenge but it was still it was
it was like there were fun matches for
this kind of event I think everybody
there was pretty well versed there
weren't too many times I really noticed
major differences uh there are certain
times when the constraints of the
controller how many buttons are right
kind of felt a little weird as opposed
to the keyboard which you can map really
well mercy specifically you can switch
from her staff her healing damage buff
staff to her like automatic pistol yeah
and on the controller the default was to
press right on the d-pad so when you're
in the middle of a fight and then you
want to switch it you have to stop
moving with your left thumb or if like I
started bringing my right thumb over
before I remapped it just because I
could keep moving and not just get shot
but you know on the keyboard I just
usually map that to Q or something which
is really quick so I'll definitely there
might be some finagling am I want to do
when I map the buttons when the open
beta launches but I know it feels really
good it feels like you know they took
their time with it um they've said they
don't want a favor one platform over the
other that's not a publisher I always
say yeah but yeah like diablo 3 i think
they did a really good job of bringing
it to consoles it wasn't as fully
fleshed out his pc they don't have
seasons but it still felt good that's
cool um yeah I mean I guess this is
probably one of the first times are
going to try and do an identical launch
for both PC and consoles for a visit
anyway I guess the other side of this
you know how did it look headed to play
what was running in 60 frames a second
to look sharp yet did it I mean the art
style sort of lends itself to some sort
of degree of scalability kind of looks
like right it yeah it was 60 frames it
looks I don't notice any visual
differences between this and pc maybe
because i don't think the art style
would really it doesn't seem like an art
style that you could really jack up on
pc for a noticeable difference I'm sure
side-by-side this probably like loads of
you know lighting and you know aliasing
and bits and bobs that are kind of not
as not as sharp as they will be on pc
but you did sure didn't feel like it was
particularly like downgraded no it was
just a normal normal playstation 4 not
this 4.5 but we'll get to that later
yeah but no it it looked it looked great
I don't have any complaints coming off
of a few hours with it I think PC might
be my preferred platform going forward
yeah although
I'm sure I'll have a few those friends
that won't be playing on PC like back
home that I'd like to jump on ps4 xbox
one with and one of the questions your
Samba 15 saying may third on consoles if
you preorder a couple of days if you
don't yeah there's a couple of different
ways of selling this actually at the
moment is the the origins edition and
then there's like special editions and
why not as some of the pre-order bonuses
for different character skins all that
stuff I wonder if that's actually if
people are interested in that at all the
people who haven't actually had a chance
to play it yet because why would you
care about skins if you hadn't actually
in you know pick to your favorite
characters are and last question on this
did you feel find yourself like favoring
certain characters over all the ones
that you wouldn't necessarily see yeah I
feel like Widowmaker I know that Bastion
the Taurus was the one that was Opie for
a while where it had the shield and I
feel like people have now gotten so good
at Widowmaker do you can just destroy
anyone if you got a good sniper so I
kind of feel like they're gonna nerf er
anyway but did you feel like less people
were using characters like that sure
yeah I i played Hanzo for one match and
I noticed someone else playing
Widowmaker throughout the matches so
they seemed comfortable but it
definitely seems like Winston was one of
the ones I mercy that those are some of
the characters that I think just for the
purpose of the event I gravitated toward
because you know again I was used to
those like those Twitter your characters
I was used to on PC and there were some
that just felt more naturally suited to
the controller right um but I've been
playing shooters on controllers for like
a wild man yeah and you know like I
counter-strike and team fortress two
were the ones that i always think about
when I'm thinking about PC shooters and
wouldn't I ended up playing both those
on consoles later I got used to them
pretty fast so i'm i'm expecting to
adapt to all the characters but there's
definitely something we said about
certain characters working better on
console like Winston I think is one of
like a good example just cuz he's some
like male a-leaping focus and then like
he said his his weapon pretty like
gravitates toward people yes sticks to
them so I noticed that a little bit yeah
cool should be interesting to see inside
a May twenty-fourth worldwide release
and the good folks at blizzard let us
know if you're going to pick that up
yourself if you're going to pick it up
on xbox one or Playstation 4 or if
you're holding out for the pc version
let us know in the comments below Mike
you've played all the games Peter we're
not gonna talk to you at all for the
first 20 minutes of the show probably
I'm just window dressing how do you feel
about over
Shh uh you know I'm intrigued by it i
usually don't get into competitive
shooters but i do like the personality
of the game and having played a little
bit of it at thing was PAX East last
year I enjoyed it but again I was going
up against people who were seemingly
really good just being an event demo
which kind of curtailed my enjoyment a
little bit so you know we'll see like
it'll depend if if I'm up to snuff when
I try to play the game but I'm curious i
definitely want to get a shot that'll be
interesting one because it's like was
like a month after gears of war if you
don't get in straight away that's
somebody ever sorry good at everything
yeah like all online shooting I got in a
titanfall right long after the fact and
i was able to adapt to that game pretty
well but i don't know that's gonna be
the same case with overwatch because it
seemed to be far less forgiving than
something like titanfall i was playing
with chris earlier today I love this I
like I really am enjoying overrun quite
a lot like more than I've enjoyed an
online shooter and quite a while like I
feel like you know growing up playing
counter-strike in quake 3 and unreal
tournament all these games like I feel
kind of bored by most first-person
shooters yeah but there's something
about overwatch I think it's just a
strategic variability that happens kind
like the first time I play team fortress
and you're like oh yeah there's like a
weed couple of these ones acceptance
editor being whatever eight characters I
forget I'm a tf2 maybe nine and there's
like this massive breath or like 16 and
up i think you know we're watching maybe
even more actually been 21 21 yeah yeah
it's really interesting I'd much anymore
I'll be curious to see what you think
about dhoom 3 multiplayer because I
brought and that was really fun i
definitely recalled something like quake
three yeah and i actually need to play
it up because i've been super down on it
since watching the trailers like yeah it
comes across maybe it's just the
marketing but it comes across like they
don't know why doom was good i don't
know how i feel about the single player
but a multiplayer was definitely good
and i went in there kind of with like
lukewarm anticipation I just kept
getting back in line keep going it so
yeah we'll see how that pans out sweet
looking forward to it another game it's
a pretty soon you've been playing for a
couple of weeks now I feel like everyone
in the office been playing a little bit
of us we had a merry kish been playing
it okay they did some live streams
couple weeks back but Dark Souls 3 yeah
you're a fan tell me your Dark Souls
lineage do you go all the way back to
demon souls or where they can come into
this so basically a blood-borne fan and
that's about it okay so aside from demon
souls have beaten all the from games at
least twice like blood-borne although
it's probably my it's one
my favorite from software games now it's
probably the one at being the fewest
times aside from demon souls demon souls
I beat once back in the day went through
it almost twice but I never I never
completely finished like a new game plus
but yeah I've had a sense of I think
dark souls 1 was my first one right I
went to two went back to demon souls
blood-borne was my game of the year last
year what's your favorite um probably
blood-borne rise point we're
disregarding my review impressions on
Dark Souls 3 probably blood-borne at
this point yeah cool yeah diceless
disregarding cuz you can't talk about it
yet yeah talk about it what Tuesday
whose bag yeah wheat from now despite
the fact that everyone's streaming it
online right now yeah we can talk about
the US version what I think of that
until talk to me about the japanese
version has been at that we've been able
to uh yeah it's it's as if I keep
telling people that it's as if Dark
Souls 1 and blood-borne kind of had a
baby okay it's it's very much I blade
through my first playthrough without a
shield the whole time which you know
blood-borne is much twitchy er was more
of a knife fight as opposed to this like
boxing match I don't know if but it's
it's more of a you can dodge very much
more often faster I just poured it into
endurance which helps you dodge more and
strength I start with a warrior went got
through most the bosses Eric hey has
gotten he's fought I think a few more
Boston I have for sure he's got into
these secret areas and I've been meaning
to go back to since I finished the game
the first time and I need to do that
soon but I have a lot of other projects
as we all do going on so I'm trying to
balance that out because I want to get
through the japanese version as well
which is I'm kind of it's weird because
they swap the dodge and the action
button so yeah yeah yeah so I'm gonna be
tapping circle and wondering why I'm
just still getting hit at team toaster
1132 says i love the lawrence story
parts of the souls games of blood-borne
how are you enjoying that aspect of it
so far it's just as obscure as they
always have been but this one does a
pretty good job of setting up the
overall structure your kind of the Lords
of cinder their 51 who well without
spoiling anything there are five lord of
cinder and then certain number of them
have like abandoned their thrones for a
little bit so you're just hunting them
down to kind of link the fire which is a
common thing
trope and dark souls you know there's
the age of fire the age of darkness it's
you have to really look deep into this
lore if you want to get much out of it
but I think for people who don't care as
much the story does a good job of
structurally setting up what you're
doing like a zelda game kind of your
hunting out these bosses these four
there's not just for boss in Dark Souls
3 but there are four major ones and then
beside from that is very obscure and
still it's it's more about tone the next
position I think and this nails a tone
just like the other ones have it seems
like anyone who's a fan of Souls game
with this age is already sort of
chomping at the bit for this one of
these 10 things i found about blood bomb
was that it appeals to I don't know what
it is about like resetting a franchisor
like starting a new one over it's a
little less of a barrier to entry for
people like I played Bob blood-borne and
I felt a lot easier to get into then I
think I was imagining dark souls to be
do you think Dark Souls 3 would be a
good place for people to start we maybe
have skipped out in the first two in
Demon's Souls yeah I actually like I
think I was Tom Pete because Pete said
he's been wanting to get into these
games for a long time yeah you want to
you've not played much of them right so
I play a lot of demon souls I didn't
finish it try playing dark souls and
sort of the same problem i had a
blood-borne same problem I think a lot
of people have where they beat their
head against the wall trying to like you
know learn the game and get good at it
you know you make a bunch of progress
and then you hit another wall right yeah
and it's that instance where you felt
like he made some progress and hit
another wall that for me was just too
much but that's you know time for me is
really precious if it was something like
I had more time or it was an assignment
i would love to really focus in on that
but for dark souls 3 i'm really going to
try this time i'm going to make it
happen because i really like blood-borne
and I'd kind of let that pass me by I
still need to go back and finish that
you know and for what you've told me
this sounds like it's a good way to get
into the series for a lot of people yeah
either if you're completely new to it or
if like even more so if blood borns one
that got you into it this is probably
the Dark Souls weirdly enough the third
the trilogy to get into it with because
it's I think it I didn't find it it's
still difficult I hit walls but maybe it
was just because I was kind of plowing
through it over a course of a few days
whereas blood-borne I let trickle over
two or three weeks I mean once you've
played that you know this is like the
fifth of these games right it's not like
the same first time you played any of
them yeah I think it does also like you
know it's really good in that
in terms of directing you where to go
dark souls people like the first dark
souls because you start off and there's
like four different directions you go
right away it's kind of overwhelming you
have to learn where you're going to get
killed a ton and then where you're
actually going to get killed only a few
times and that's the way you go this one
kind of balances giving you options but
not too many so I think the most paths I
could take it any one time was three or
four but then there were never less than
two most of the time so it like I felt
like I could explore but I didn't feel
like I was being completely overwhelmed
so I think in that respect it's always
like structurally this might be the game
to get into also a lot of people in the
chowder talking about how it's been
running on PC what have you been playing
on mostly what are the guys live stream
on actually as well they live streamed
on pc i believe ok i was playing on ps4
and i noticed some hiccups but I don't
know like whether I'd speak that until
it's closer to launch I'm sure that I
have like a patch for it you know what
Eric was saying that they have a day one
patch which is hoping to resolve some of
the framerate e stuff but yeah ps4 was
looking all right um there were definite
framerate issues um which like you said
the patch hopefully fixed that pc it's
not locked at 30 like a console is ok so
you can you can jack it up the frame
rate I notice on people playing pc the
framerate look completely fine it looked
great any other technical issues there
you know just minor here and there
nothing huge but yeah I think pending
that patch I'd rather play it on pc
right just because it's a game that
requires precision I don't want frame
rates ever be an issue like that one
second i'm going to miss a Dodge or
something yeah fair enough a dark souls
3 is out in japan as of april 12 or
sorry march 24th but adds at april 12
here in north america and in the rest of
the world in europe as well and the rest
of the world that is north america while
you book said zealand in Africa look
forward to Dark Souls 3 coming out in a
couple of weeks when is the review
embargo chopping them a week from today
oh really at some point alright so next
week a week ahead of time that's good
thank you so much Michael my hearty
getting I said the lowdown on this
visual game yeah now we're here to talk
about different types of games not
visual games but real real okay
I'm gonna call it that's the new time on
games but real games virtual reality
Peter bran I mean it right now we're all
in no you're not this is the real world
this is not virtual reality I know you
spent most of last week with the stupid
dumb oculus goggles on your face I want
to talk to you about that first of all
did you have lines around your face this
weekend yes no I didn't last this
weekend but no lines you get lines in
your face for solid 20 minutes okay
great tech technical goes off after
doing a bit of like scuba diving it's
almost exactly like taking there you go
except no fishies although I'm sure they
have the fishies for your demo as well
yes coming soon so you spent all last
week or what seems like the majority of
last week playing lots of different
games on the oculus rift I actually
focused on a small handful of games okay
I wasn't trying to go for the entire
gamut of the launch lineup because we're
trying to review some game so in order
to do that I have to focus a little bit
yeah so you're playing co-op games like
chrono see Valkyrie courtesy Valkyrie
Lucky's tale I tried playing some adrift
before I got a sick uh yeah I realized
like really okay it's good zoned out
first wasn't a joke that's my thing to
say uh so I guess I want to talk to you
you're like the litmus test right you're
the person who's actually spent a bunch
of time minik because most of the people
i've talked to you about this have spent
you know 20 minutes on on a show floor
somewhere or i've spent an hour maybe at
a developer's so what were they like
time frames you were using Youkilis for
and how did it feel coming out of that
yeah well coming out of it definitely
depends on what experience you're
playing I used it anywhere from five
minutes in a sitting to a couple hours
at a time and you certainly feel odd
after a long session coming out of it
because you moved from one your sense of
presence has now shifted back to reality
and with that looking at my watch was
really strange because everything yeah
the passage of time just it it's skewed
slightly that's a bit weird yeah it's
not so it's not like I thought only 20
minutes had passed and it had been two
hours [ __ ] eXistenZ
but I mean it's on the order of maybe
what felt like an hour was to like
something like okay it can it can it can
be pretty dramatic is that the case was
regular video games maybe as well it is
yeah it feels more yeah but crazy
calling you when you pair that that
feeling with what you get from VR which
is you know immersion even if it's a
game that is not like a first-person
experience of trying to recreate reality
right like no matter what anything
you're planning in VR that's all you're
looking at that's right as you can see
no matter where you turn your head yeah
so you are immersed in that experience
even if it's not the world that you're
immersed in specifically so like I play
a lot of rocket League just randomly for
like you know 20 minutes here or there
or maybe like an arrow here there and
what I find is a lot of the time I'm
thinking about just regular day-to-day
stuff like I'm taking about my taxes or
thinking about what I got to do in a
week I'm not really like actively
involved in what's happening on the
screw the screen in Virtual Reality do
you feel like you're sort of more
engaged with the moment to moment what
the hell is going on or does your mind
still wander it's an escape really yeah
yeah I mean it I can't make it any
simpler than that yeah like really you
at least I felt very detached when I was
playing a game that I was invested in
mentally um you know all those things I
was just describing a minute ago kind of
inform this this isolation that you have
from yourself even to a degree because
there's nothing to distract you it
really isn't and so like what's it like
taking it off and then calling coming
back as any like physical aspect to it
that's like trying to recenter yourself
or is it more of a like when you come
off a road across here and you're like
oh ok now feed back on terra firma and
I'm kind of I'm used to this uh if
things felt a little alien for the first
minute or two because you really are
acklam like as much as it takes you to
acclimate to VR coming out of it
requires acclamation as well and you
know tell you I can understand how what
I'm saying sounds like maybe extreme or
somewhat contrived but it but at least
myself I was very much into the
experiences that I was engaging with and
coming out of them felt very strange
very strange not in a bad way and not in
a way that lasted for a long time or
gave me an existential crisis
or anything like that but it was
definitely like okay this is actually my
day this is what I'm doing I'm not
following this Fox around the woods I'm
not crawling through a dungeon you know
fighting monsters yeah that kind of
thing not that I ever really believed I
was but I think you get what I'm saying
so it cuz to me that sends that what
you're talking about their sounds far
more I don't know like impactful then
maybe any one of the individual video
game experiences like just the sort of
the sense that exists around using
virtual reality and the way in which it
sort of messes with your psyche a little
bit yeah that almost sounds like what's
more interesting than the games
themselves is that is that why you're so
excited about it at this moment yes the
sort of the grander feelings that VR
gives me is what has me interested in
what it can do for gaming but also what
it can do for passive experiences like
video it's it's it's really important
that people give this a try and really
think about how it makes them feel
before writing it off because VR is
freaking special it's very different
from everything we've done before and
you know I put up my review for Lucky's
tale today which is the game that's
bundled with every head said it's really
middling it's not that great a third
person colorful platform yeah and you
know what like it's it's fine it's
totally fine but it doesn't really sell
what's important about VR and so I
stated as much and some commenter was
saying like oh you really shouldn't be
doing this because then people are going
to think that VR isn't that great like
you should really try to like prop it up
so everyone likes VR and it's like no
because the the tech is there if you
read the oculus rift review you can see
why I think that's important but the
games right now still need to catch up
eval curry oculus or Kronos those are
both really great games but they're
still just kind of tiptoeing into the
waters of what VR can do yeah let's talk
about the games a little bit actually
there's a couple of questions in a child
about us habla Derek asks what racing
games are forged I know project cars
supports yes the rift I saw drew Scanlon
a Giant Bomb stas standing up and
sitting in the passenger side of the car
and then looking at a headless version
of himself nice that sounds really
exciting to me as a big racing fan is
that does that is that exciting to you I
play
of it at an event a while back and it
was it was pretty good I mean for me
that that's really an in the same with
Lucky's tale and Chronos these are
examples of taking traditional games and
having VR sort of like breathe a little
bit of new life into them by changing
the way that you interact with the space
and the the identity of whatever it is
you're interacting with this there's a
saga one no but so I mean I think
there's going to be this initial way
that's kind of exciting where you play
something familiar in VR and it feels
different and new but the same way we're
tired of tech demos er now we're going
to get tired of experiences like guess
what it's that favorite racing gave me
yours and now you're in the front seat
and you can look around like that's
that's gonna pass yeah it's a gimmick
right now I felt that way already when I
played the TrackMania turbo yeah one in
VR cuz it's like this is awful
experience like it's fun that you put
this in this is dumb but like yeah it
wasn't exactly a very like the VR aspect
of it did not anything at all and in
fact that the talking about a drift
which use gave you reviewed on gamespot
Michael yeah five at a ten right yep
didn't sound like it was particularly
you know it sound like a game that was
made as a decent tech demo for rift but
then there wasn't really much else to it
when you took it out of the rift yeah
and there wasn't really much to it in
the Rev tires it's hellas it's
definitely worth playing in VR over pc
if you have the option it looks gorgeous
on pc especially when you come out of
the han for the space station you're
exploring and then you kind of look down
on earth and then later on the game
you're kind of ritz you're on the other
side of Earth or yeah you're right
you're looking down it's nighttime over
Asia right it's gorgeous but the VR
gives that sense of scale and height and
kind of sense a place yeah that really
lends itself well to that game
especially because the sound design is
really good which is funny because
there's not much sound to the game but i
think they now like that kind of
environment that vacuum you're in but
the game itself despite some really good
moments of great writing with the
characters it's you know it's a
environmental clues and audio logs and
what not gonna flush out these
characters whose loading simulator yeah
yeah so those are great but it's really
tedious to get there the movement at
first is novel you're using thrusters
it's kind of like you know gravity the
movie and you
you know it's but it seems like that's
telling you there's danger a lot because
you're collecting these oxygen canisters
but those survival aspects feel forced
the movement after a while becomes kind
of like tedious you're moving very
slowly you get the boost later on but
once you get the boost the distances you
have to travel or increase so it's
almost like it just scales to the point
of mitigating the boost got it yeah it
just doesn't seem like it knows what it
wants to be there's the survival aspects
that didn't really do much for me and
then those discourage me from exploring
which it also seemed to be telling me to
do and the movement itself was kind of
all so discouraging me from doing either
them add Joey hosking the twit shot says
no killer opted at the fines of your and
that something that a lot of people are
saying at the moment is that like we
need that one big game to do it so if
you could like pick the game that's at
least out right now Peter which is
that's out right now yeah what's the
best version what's the best game to
work on view right now that that's
doesn't sound like it's it doesn't sound
like it's a killer app anyway no I mean
look I I'm gonna break one of your rules
okay I'm gonna say the game that I think
is gonna be most impactful is the one
that you have played right the oculus
touch demo the oculus touch demo where
you are engaging with someone who is in
an entirely different physical space I
think that is a sort of experience that
will make people just unequivocally
agree that VR is special yeah and their
end like I mean you were doing it you
were throwing a ball to see who was in a
different room from you it was really
strange for those who don't know it this
is essentially the you are you were a
wireframe head and fists and arms
because you've got the oculus touch them
controllers as well yeah and you were
essentially standing against another
wire frame head and set of arms and
talking because it's all you've got
headsets as well and interacting and
throwing picking up items and throwing
them to the other person juggling and
playing all this stuff and what the
weirdest thing was that during this
whole demo we would keep like
high-fiving right cuz like if I was like
a really simple version of touch that we
do with this other individual who I had
never actually met before and then after
the demo he walked into the room and the
two of us without even thinking about it
and I fine I was like wait we've
actually never even been the same room
as nursing but we have
created this like really crazy we
communicated even though we were never
in the same room at all yeah and so I
think one of the big challenges that
oculus is facing right now is it doesn't
have those controllers to enable the
sort of experiences that you're
describing right vr can add not VR in
general rift and you know its
competitors can add things to games but
it really requires a lot more hardware
to make virtual reality possible the way
that people imagine it to be which is
that the total physical immersion vive
has the advantage right now because it's
shipping with those controllers yeah
they're available now oculus I think we
still have to wait a couple months are
those touch controllers and something
like job simulator survive yeah you know
it's a cute little game but you are
really interacting with things like you
get the sense that like yeah I'm putting
my laptop in the toaster and hit and go
and I'm photocopying like you know my
tone yeah like whatever like you
actually are engaging with this stuff in
a little bit of an extra sort of sort of
special way yeah on top of just the
visual immersion that VR supplies so I
don't think that there is a killer app
for rift right now my favorite is
Chronos okay it brings back the fixed
camera system that made games like
resident evil have such great scene
composition yeah room to room so a lot
of opportunities really great shots and
you are the the camera where you look is
where the camera looks around the room
and on top of that it's got it's got
great gameplay it's like really fun
dungeon exploring with you know the
basic description is sort of Dark Souls
type combat and that game right now is
the one game that I want to go back and
keep playing but it's only available in
oculus so that's where I have to go play
it that's interesting because this isn't
what people would consider or what they
would imagine necessarily when you say
oh this great oculus rift game because
essentially your head is just taking the
place of one of the camera points and
resident evil like yes you're just
looking right what is it about that said
that is it is there something inherent
about the control and what that adds to
the game or is it just a good game that
has this novel control or novel
viewpoint uh well the viewpoint I
wouldn't say is novel though I do think
I understand you're saying it's rare
these days it's a dying art which i
think is how i put in in one of our
features but what it really does is it
allows so even it seemed like this right
here right
he was walking on that shelf is a really
small character if you had free range of
the camera you'd be thrown it all over
the place like yeah trying to look at
objects like scenes in this game are
composed in such a way to evoke certain
emotions and feelings out of you and
that is really important and so when you
mix that with a little bit of added
immersion that comes from the headset
it's a really great combination even if
it doesn't dominate like what I think
the game is it's an undeniable part of
it it's also like a big shift in
perspective a little bit of Chronos
knows it was quite a while it was back
in Germany last year one of the the
things that I sort of didn't realize
about playing 3rd person games because
there's another one as well what's the
what's the other third person the snow
edge of nowhere oh yeah which is Omni a
key yes which is another you know
third-person game but what I didn't
really realize until I play these games
was that it's like having the television
in your face so like the amount of
detail the perspective actually kind of
feels more like first person in that you
feel very intimately connected to the
environment yes even though it's in
third person yes there is definitely
that sense of intimacy you know it's as
simple as like playing Lucky's tale your
this Fox you're running around the woods
and one point you get away from this
really wide expansive environment and
you're walking through a hollow tree
trunk right and in that moment I could
feel the space around me like closing in
right like there was a definite sense I
don't have claustrophobia but whatever I
could relate to that like that kind of
feeling and for yeah like a regular
third person game that we all know and
love like vr can add a little bit to it
at least to bring you into the the
moment at hand in the game Resident Evil
oculus riemeck the resin needle team
says they're working in VR really yeah
they they start talking about that i
think at TGS last year alright so i mean
i would love that but only if it's fixed
camera i think your relic exactly right
i'm just not the problem yeah no I mean
like one of the reasons the original
resident evil was so good and one of the
reasons a remake is also be loved is
because his technique has a lot of value
even though it was born from a place of
technical deficiency it actually it's
pretty a pretty sweet sometimes yeah
they sort of stumbled into AB accident
while trying to fix like a believability
yeah yeah so I would love to see resin
he'll go back to doing that especially I
mean sure VR otherwise cool I last point
on this when are we get when is the vibe
going to be officially out of 10 we have
a review for that
so I believe it starts shipping next
week our review should be april fifth
right now we have not the final consumer
version close to though I mean it's
essentially an analog but we don't we
can say for certainty we should be
getting ours any day so hopefully yeah
no problems there will at least have the
hardware review up on Tuesday cool and
again with games to follow how you
feeling about each or the other right
now wat see what's your preference after
spending all that time with the rift and
having a decent man with the the preview
version of the five I mean cost of
Kostas even a factor I mean I really
appreciate how vive has just more
options open so that if you want to be
in one of those experiences where you
can manipulate objects where you can
walk around your environment you can do
a little bit of that with riff I think
it's like a three by three foot space
right but with vibe you just have so
much more room to move and interact with
things so right now my preferences wife
cool alright review next week thank you
so much Peter Brown let us know what you
think about the future of the virtual
reels in the comment box below Mike my
hardy what do you think about all this
I'm have you had much experience using
either of them uh yeah so I went to an
oculus rift recently the day before gtc
started okay then I went all my demos a
GC we're all oculus or five yeah most of
you are suffering yeah and then
PlayStation I did a couple FPS exit if
you playstation vr things and i'm
definitely sold i'm on board a adrift
like i said was better in VR i might go
back and play a few more hours I want to
play Chronos at some point definitely
because I played about two hours total
of that and it really between like its
Zelda influences almost like Dark Souls
like combat kind of and then you know a
few other mechanics p was telling me
about and the resin evil camera angles
well what did you talk about when these
are cannock so essentially you are sent
back in time to sort of save humanity
and this portal you go through you can
run on Scott yeah you can only enter
place to the artist on one time per year
okay when you die you get sent back in
time so the theory is every time you die
you gain a year forever i hear you gain
you become more inherently proficient in
magic okay less inherently proficient
with physical attacks right so as you
age you sort of evolved as a character
in more than just physical appearance
but then at the same time that it kind
of devalues a mechanic a little bit
because you also gain perks for every
decade you could grow older so you can
just like real life just like real life
yeah you have AARP you can attract now
like tax brackets yeah sure yeah but
yeah that's got a really interesting
death mechanic but anyway yeah I wish
that game was not just a VR game at the
moment cuz I think more people really
should play right Chronos I need that
you could release this game is not a vo
game I think I think that there is a
chance it is coming out on pc and it's
not a hundred percent sure but i know
right now it's just on rift alright
alright we're not talking about PC just
for a second right now we're gonna talk
about the PlayStation let's have a chat
about the PlayStation I chin or a
chinwag Carol hit the PlayStation 4.5 a
good friend over at Kotaku Patrick
klavik broke a story last week saying
that the there was word basically around
GDC and they had a bunch of sources and
unnamed sources that said that there was
a upgrade coming to the PlayStation 4 or
an upgraded version of the PlayStation 4
which was going to support have a no
meteor GPU illness and that would
probably support 4k resolution and that
this had probably some sort of tying
into the abilities of the restrictions
around the PlayStation VR and since then
there's been wall street journal reports
basically saying the same sort of
corroboration of like it's so funny the
original news piece about this had you
know informational apparently like chasm
McDonald from kotaku UK I just overheard
two people in line right as well at GDC
literally talking about the space
station 4.5 well that's a code name or
not and how it's going to fit into
Sony's planned first of all initial
reactions to this Peter what do you
think it's been a long time since we've
seen a console had an iteration like I
can only think of the 32 exes like the
the latest one that I can think of is
this something is it a good idea is it
strange it's strange but it's a good
idea I mean I think it's not from what
everyone is saying right now it's not
going to impact current PlayStation 4
owners there are not plans for exclusive
games based on the current rumors right
it's
plan for cross compatibility while I can
understand some people might feel
slighted like oh what the hell i bought
an old ps4 now i have to buy a new one
if i want to have like the best graphics
at playstation 4 you know can you do
welcome to pc ownership yeah we're all
gonna exactly and also you've had a
PlayStation 4 for a while and you know
what you still the same games and the
visuals are that important like that's
your imperative to have to pay for it
and I don't think it's a bad thing do
you think they need us because we know
we're talking about that they like to be
able to say oh this console generation
we r 1 for 10 years and were what are we
three and a half four years in at the
moment playstation 4 and xbox one are
already kind of flagging a little bit do
you think playstation 4 needs us I do i
do i think if you look at tvs right now
all right everything is a freaking 4k TV
this thing is not there's no way they're
going to be able to get a decent price
console that does 4k gaming I mean
that's literally like it's four times
the resolution of 1080 right uh not a
ram not quite okay it's less than that
but essentially like for video video is
very important part of PlayStation and
what's going on yes for ps5 better be
able to fly says samuel cram i hate your
creepy face thank you that's a benefit
of the park out for you uh yeah i mean
look i don't know i don't understand
that but why people would have an issue
here unless they feel salty about
spending money but you know it i think
it really comes down to being 4k capable
for for video more than anything else
yeah Mike what's your thought on this
cuz I I game that I've been playing
recently quantum break and we'll get to
xbox one another while apparently that
game runs around 720 and Jenny its
temporal 1080p why they take for 720p
frames and loyal but it like it's the
best game I've seen looking on an xbox
one so like resolution to me I overdrive
in okay I can't looks pretty good
contrast makes a real pop so am but I
like it I've never really understood a
lot of the heat behind this like
fixation is specifically resolution when
you look at like you can have a high
resolution game looks like a deep
[ __ ] ass because of the like
the other effects they're working on it
and what do you think about this your
playstation 4 honor yeah uh it's if it's
gonna help the VR experience and because
the PlayStation VR I think like most
people that's well it's the most
affordable one at this point the option
like you know not factoring in if you
need a new console and the move
controllers and everything which I'm
excited for PSP are just because I'd
like to see that that might be you know
ostensibly the first one I have in my
living room if it can help in that
respect and I'm on board for it i don't
feel slighted at all like one of my
roommates was saying he did at first but
then I well you had what three years of
that is I think like three years of the
ps4 it that that was an investment
you've had three years of a lot of good
games like you're not you've they're a
bunch of games that you got to play in
that time period and like said there's
not gonna be any exclusives when the 4.5
or whatever they end up calling it is
gonna be out this hasn't existed in
handheld gaming as well here's like a
reasons is a new revision of the DS like
sometimes they do make games which only
work on you know 3d s or whatever it was
like we saw a Nintendo do that with
Hyrule warriors legends on 3ds sorry
Ziva Blake chronicles was exclusive to
new 3ds but then recently they spit out
Hyrule warriors legends and that was not
exclusive and people were kind of upset
with how I ran in the regular 3ds but
Nintendo hardware is generally pretty
underpowered anyway especially for a
port of a game from an HD console do you
see Sony doing something like if you
trade in your old at your own
PlayStation 4 will give you an upgrade
for like 150 boxes only to see game stop
doing that right yeah I don't see Sony
carry one way or the other you don't
think like the PR battle over this that
they know they might bend a knee and
just say okay right because what we're
doing because if it is literally just a
GPU up Graves I mean wouldn't the the
wonderful world of the internet you like
well if there's only one part of the
machine and you can console gaming is
the weirdest sex sector of the
electronics market in the world
everything else has so many different
variants and skis and this that and the
other i think you know we're used to
that in everything but consoles i think
people are going to just understand and
get used to it maybe they'll cry in the
beginning but i don't think sony is
facing an uphill battle here i think yet
maybe it'll be a little blip on the
radar people who are upset but that'll
go away pretty fast
thank you both for telling me your
thoughts about the PlayStation 4.5
little bit of a shift of gears here at
it's interesting we're talking about the
PlayStation 4 i've been having an
upgrade because it is the more powerful
and the the game the console of the two
that are currently I guess fighting with
each other at the moment that has the
sort of superiority when it comes to the
graphical processing so I want to shift
gears a little bit and talk about xbox
one and Phil Spencer said you will
actually see us come out with a new
hardware capability during this
generation at an investor call a couple
of months ago this has been something
that he's sort of like touched on a
couple of pieces during a generation
during a generation not this gen
conscious generation so do you think
that the xbox one being the console of
the two that most people would say is
probably requiring an upgrade do you
think that they'll go with similar route
I think that they certainly could and
let's see why they wouldn't especially
because they exist in the pc specs where
this is something that they're pretty
used to write yes and look both both of
the GPUs in each of the consoles are
created by AMD their manufacturing
processes in terms of how small and and
cool they can make chips right have
improved quite a bit I believe both
consoles started at 28 nanometers and
now they're down to like 14 nanometer
manufacturing processes it so the same
hardware developer working with both you
know partners I mean it stands to reason
that they will approach Microsoft if
sony has approached them or they've
approached Sony it just seems to make
sense to me I don't see why they
wouldn't the other thing about this is i
guess is that they're sort of unified
the windows platform azad are listed
that's the direction they've been going
in frustrating and the Xbox originally
was always this big plan to try and get
the pc space in the living room to to
own that space which it seems really
weird that in 2016 we still don't have a
real leader there in fact it's kind of
broken into all these other things like
steam machines and you know for a while
there is house shuttle pcs might be the
way it all goes do eventually do we
start to see the walls break down then
between because if the xbox one
essentially becomes a upgradable console
then it's almost only different to pc in
branding about said oh no now services
my friend services like watch pc gamers
don't need xbox live oh yeah good point
I me
you're gonna if those two really become
unified Microsoft will have to back off
some of their their practices to make
money off of consoles which are
traditionally sold really close to cost
or under cost so unless they do that I
don't I don't think they could bring
both markets together and make both
parties happy but maybe that's maybe
they're trying to offset that but what
they're doing with quantum break with
the whole you can repurchase this via
the Windows Store they're trying to like
take some self-control is the same with
gears of war 10 um I mean yeah there
might be part of that but that's no
one's happy about that I think if
anything that's been in turn people off
yeah I mean you look at something like
that and you immediately say but steam
does it this you know like there's
already a better example out there than
what they're trying to do on PC and just
like games for windows live I can't see
this effort lasting long enough to
actually lead to any meaningful positive
change for Microsoft it's only going to
be a detriment over time Mike doing on
Xbox one yep would you be looking
forward to an upgraded version of it or
I mean if the PlayStation 4 ends up
getting its getting a GPU push then what
does not even the xbox one the graphical
part here is gonna be real fun than
right yeah I don't know I yeah I would
be you know up for it I've never there
are a few games I've noticed you know
like most of time when I choose between
ps4 and xbox one I go ps4 just because
the majority of my friends I play with
or on that it's not always a graphical
you no consideration but I have to
imagine that Microsoft was thinking
about doing something this generation
not that that's what they said the whole
PlayStation 4.5 might be kind of the
impetus for them to consider it even
more strongly hmm yeah i'd be up for it
I don't know that I would be you know
jumping at the gun to get it right away
only because like I said I'd like
quantum break looks great on the xbox
one I think we're playing like rise of
the Tomb Raider DLC later I've never had
I have never had like a situation where
i said i really wish i was playing us on
ps4 just because it would look that much
better right you know in that case i
would probably just go to pc if I did
it's that much of an upgrade I had a bit
of that over the witcher because i
thought because i saw people playing on
playstation 4 and i was playing on the
xbox one and it actually did like i
could notice that there was the sharper
looking on the playstation 4 of course
on pc like I can't even look at the pc
version right
disgusting to me I have a wild theory ok
go for it both companies are potentially
planning this because the Nintendo NX
will be more powerful than the current
iterations ah no I'm not joking Christ
no I like dude that that's that's a
hundred percent of possibility yeah yeah
thanks I a counterpunch to Nintendo's
swing yeah what I me I mean if they
don't get mad with the most powerful
console in the world that be quite a
statement yes yeah so alright that's all
I just know I just want to throw that
out there because I honestly people have
there have been rumors that they are
working towards a device that is the
most powerful and if that's true these
companies have to do it could we be
looking at an e3 where we see three
consoles us oh I hope so that would be
so much fun I want a wild and crazy III
so bad and I don't want it to be just
about VR I really don't want to be just
about VR well GDC was maybe a bit too
much on the VR yes I'm obviously that's
not like so a CEO super past two years
yeah anyway what have to see interesting
times I have a car waiting three already
have far away from me three two months
two months and change march april may
june three months three months three new
console could be coming i let us know
what you're excited for is it the
playstation 4.5 the xbox one point five
they're not gonna call it a point five
because in that screws them up if they
need to put out another iteration three
years Oh point six well what happened to
point to one through but I color the 4.2
4.1 the 4k and then example doesn't do
4k then it's gonna be no new 4k video Oh
God and they call it the xbox too haha
yeah why not the xbox three two if
you're talking about like cleat like you
know a box to lending the identity of
what Microsoft gaming is then Xbox to is
just as good as anything else they can
come up with they call it Xbox dude
outdoors thing in the world that's awful
the fourth Xbox is the xbox drew make a
bet if this comes out whether it's
called that or not okay yeah what's the
bet drive to shave my beard again oh but
I like your beard okay when you shave
your beard and I'll shave my head for a
five-hundred-dollar donate wait wait
wait I want to shave something why can't
the body parts like a poodle lb idea by
the poodle anyway I don't know a three
way back complicates things okay I'm
washing my hands I'll let you
okay you should be real I'll shave my
head ok if it's called Xbox to you
should be removed no no you shave your
head I'll shave my head yeah and if it's
not you'll shave your bid Phil Spencer
you're reading things I this is the sort
of bed that I'd like to make ok yeah
looking forward to it Phil Spencer if
you're watching I've got a whole I'll
come up with an Excel spreadsheet a
better names than xbox to take your pick
if you're watching this on demand please
put your thoughts in the comments would
you like an Xbox too would you have a
Playstation 4.5 and what other
alternative names would be better xbox
on the Xbox y'all got they would call it
they would totally calling it would you
play baked into it o-tama from the
comments below I completely changed up
the naming convention like in general
like the X cube DX yeah just the X
sphere like the X cubed ya know alright
I'm just trying to get it on a bed
neither of your xbox or xbox then they
call it the xbox was he at the kid table
what else are they call it xbox I guess
the playstation one was the ps1 was the
other version of it that was only a fun
style yeah that wasn't like a
functionally different i took out the
serial port Danny so I could know my
game shark in there anymore yeah you
could get that screen and stick it on
the front and I've affordable
PlayStation I have that's freaky really
it's not very portable it's not an
optical drive whatever it's like one of
those portable record players yeah the
wind blows and suddenly the music's
going twice as fast okay we're gonna
wrap this one up and marrakesh in a bad
at 35 minutes x gonna play the best
named DLC I've ever heard rise of the
Tomb Raider the cold darkness awakened I
[ __ ] you didn't come up with us the
colds darkness awakened the cold
darkness awakes what's called it was the
last one the but Baba Yaga no I'm
serious yeah I'm pretty positive area
was the last the rise of the Tomb Raider
deals he called Baba Yaga the cold
darkness awake
oh yeah okay mutters it's not even
awakens I know the cold darkness
awakened its I don't think there's a sad
Star Wars spin-off the cold darkness
comma awakened the cold darkness
awakened it's called accord ex yeah
there's not much tweaking you could do
that title to make it good no there is
called the cold darkness or just the
darkness awaken the darkness yeah Jackie
Estacado wake up there's new DLC yell
out that lara croft vs jackie estacado
in this Bobby pretty good what is like
Ralph Macchio is the final boss who he's
like the bolt the villain and karate kid
oh really well actor that plays about
where did that come from work I have no
idea ok great that you said a minute ago
or someone maybe if we get the
PlayStation 4 k then when you play the
darkness you can watch to kill a
mockingbird in 4k how about that goodbye
about that alright we're almost done
here Mary's gonna play the rise of the
tomb with radar the cold darkness
awakened pretty soon before we sign off
no Peter what are you working on against
what this week quantum Baker [ __ ] wanek
quantum bake get those croutons quantum
bacon I really want croutons now quantum
break review review of Chronos vibe
review um gosh that's that's it it's a
bunch stuff there's probably more I just
don't want to think about it no worries
Michael mehar d what about yourself Dark
Souls 3 at all yeah Dark Souls 3 gonna
play doom it that might be next week um
working on some new project which we
should build an ounce like tomorrow I
think I don't know and then mainly
though Saturday night he's excited
Syracuse Orange on Final Four let's go q
centrist no not this era q citrus rights
don't do that that's mad March March
Madness mad March and sizable yes so
much madness all right watch us play unc
hopefully it oops we don't get destroyed
like I expect us to okay but whatever
that's what I thought about the last
three games you guys some positive vibes
out there man yeah don't you know how
the universe works like you're not
watching the secret no I'm ready I
browse through that thing
this is awful we're uh yeah carsales
well done well yeah best of luck eight
o'clock in the CBS it okay is well that
Dark Souls 3 gonna be on CBS eight
o'clock o'clock nutrient and the
roommate they're running a traitor for
dark souls 3 during the march madness
yeah finals no not the final they do
that with halo 3 during yeah was a super
bowl alright let's wrap this up thank
you so much peter brandt pike my hearty
for coming on thank you to richard lee
carrying his ridiculous fishing rod
camera thing i love us it's amazing
you're a champion mean hammer heading
down to blizzards tomorrow to record
some fun stuff so be more about that on
the site in about a month i'm eric a
generic a dumb [ __ ] in the back house
ever putting on a great show thank you
so much everyone in the twit shot for
hanging out and sending in their
questions thank you so much for watching
us on youtube on gamespot com I think
you so much for subscribing to us on
iTunes or stitcher or whatever to help
make sure to rate and review us and we
really appreciate it wheel it back next
week tuesday to PM pacific Mariga be
back in a little while with rise of the
Tomb Raider the cold darkness awaken
we're also going to do an oculus rift VR
stream on Friday so we'll see you then
make sure you hit the subscribe button
and enjoy great week of video games
adios